it looked like you know judging by the
weather data it was a pretty extreme
event yesterday meaning that the ones
the wind gust that came through
was almost hurricane strength
is not racing tomorrow that was a
serious situation of trying to get their
wing out before the storm arrived and
unfortunately it came sort of
at a time which wasn't ideal and yeah we
had to scramble and I was impressed by
the amount of people that actually came
to help and we had members from other
teams and obviously a lot of the the
cell GP Tech Team involved as well and
trying to secure the wing and platform
and and get it down without any
any incidents and the situation
obviously escalated a bit with the
breeze and it was some of the most wind
I've probably ever seen in my life so
yeah it was a pretty real situation we
were very fortunate we were able to get
the the boat in the shed
um seconds before that weather storm hit
and uh yeah fortunately the river was
safe and minimal damage yeah look what
happened yesterday was
really unfortunate for for everyone
involved for the league for all of the
teams particularly for Canada
it was a very difficult situation with a
weather front coming through and trying
to anticipate exactly when that was
going to hit the fleet was was and
always is with the weather you know
Mother Nature doesn't always play ball
and this was a case where it really
caught us out big time